hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
here's stephen colbert doing
comedy you're in the communications
department okay the press isn't part of
the communications department
essentially you know
not to be reductive but it's like the
public relations for the white house
okay how does it feel as essentially top
pr person when your boss the president
is getting dragged in the press like
when you see some idiot in late night
making a joke about your boss
i'm asking for a friend you're asking
for a friend yes how does that how does
that feel dial that friend up um
so
you know i think
you all have a job
for the american public to make them
laugh
and
we have a job for the american public to
deliver and you know we understand like
we understand that you have you have
your job we have our jobs absolutely not
and the president gets that the
president absolutely gets that okay good
yeah all right
is it going to come on
oh that's where you were going
to come on because he's been on kimmel
and he's been on fallon but he hasn't oh
you're keeping track you're keeping
since he's been president many times
we're dear friends obviously he loves
you and i'm sure he's watching and i'm
sure he's watching sure yeah
so
when when you all uh you know came into
office 18 months ago one of the things
uh the goals stated was to kind of
repair the relationship between that
press office and the press how was that
going and how do you do that when some
members of the press won't agree on uh
what reality is
some members of the press some members
of the press okay
um
look i i think
the way that i see it is my job our job
is to
make sure that we are delivering the
facts delivering uh what the president's
agenda is and that's our focus and
that's what we
we do every day and we really worked
have worked the last 18 19 months to
really repair that relationship and
there's always going to be a give and
take always always going to be
um a little pull and tug but that's okay
that's democracy that's the you know the
freedom of the press the independency of
the press and it's you know it's we see
it as a as an opportunity to really have
to be able to communicate to all of you
to all of the american people on the
work that we're doing every single day
you